est ce que vous vous demandez parfois
pourquoi les choses sont telles qu'elles
sont et pourquoi elles ne sont pas
autrement
je m'appelle cyrus torse et j'essaie de
répondre à cette question depuis plus de
cinq ans sur cette chaîne youtube
j'aime comprendre le monde et l'humanité
autant que j'aime changer de visage sur
cette chaîne vous apprendrai et vous
ferez découvrir plein de concepts dans
certains qui peuvent même impact et
votre vie tous les jours sans que vous
vous en rendiez compte
ça peut être de la philosophie de la
politique des discussions de la
psychologie des sketches des expériences
des voyages il n'y a pas de règle quand
on est curieux alors il n'y a pas de
règle sur cette chaîne sauf pour
s'abonner